اكدت روسيا اسقاطتها من جنائيه مرتبطه
بالتمرد المسلح لمجموعه فاجنر في اطار
تسويه مع المجموعه وصفها الرئيس
البيلاروسي بانها لم تعالج المشكله كما
يجب من ناحيته قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ان القوات المسلحه اوقفت فعليا وقوع
حرب اهليه بينما شكك رئيس الحرس الوطني في
ضلوع استخبارات اجنبيه في محاوله تمرد
ديفاكنا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الذي يمكن فهمه من
تصريحات الرئيس الروسي بشان المخاطر التي
شكلها تمرد فاغنر والى اي حد يمثل ما حدث
نهايه ازمه ام بدايتها ما مغزى تحضير
الرئيس البلروسي من قضايا عالقه في
التسويه بين السلطات الروسيه ومجموعه
واتهامات روسيا للغرب باحتمال الضلوع في
تمرد المجموعه وما مدى امكانيه تاثر
العمليات الروسيه في اطار الحرب على
اوكرانيا بتمرد فاغنر في ضوء تاكيد مالكها
رفض عناصره الانضمام للجيش وما مصير
مواقعهم في جبهات القتال
[موسيقى]
غداه تخييره مقاتلي مجموعه فاجنر بين
التعاقد مع وزاره الدفاع او العوده الى
بيوتهم او الذهاب الى بيلاروسيا وبعد
تاكيد السلطات الروسيه اسقاطتها من جنائيه
مرتبطه بالتمرد المسلح للمجموعه قال
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان القوات
المسلحه والقوات الامنيه الروسيه اوقفت
فعليا وقوع حرب اهليه بسبب تمرد فاغنر وان
الجيش والشعب لم ينضم الى صفوف من وصفه
بالمتمردين تصريحات بوتين التي ادلى بها
امام قيادات عسكريه وامنيه روسيه تزامنت
مع حديث رئيس الحرس الوطني الروسي يعني
انه لا يستبعد ضلوع استخبارات اجنبيه في
محاوله التمرد المسلح الذي شهدته البلاد
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ذكرت بحسب وكاله
نوفوستي ان مجموعه فاجنر التي وصل قائدها
تستعد لتسليم اعدادها العسكري للوزاره
فيما بدا تاكيدا لما ذكره من قبل عن رفض
مقاتله التعاقد مع وزاره دفاع الروسيه
الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاشينكو الذي
نسب له الفضل في التوسط لانهاء التمرد
فاغنر قال ان التوتر بين الجيش الروسي
وفاغنير لم تتم معالجته كما يجب وانه لن
يمنع مواطنيه من الانضمام الى المجموعه
كما حذر من اثار كارثيه لانهيار روسيا
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع تنضم الينا من موسكو
السيده اولغا الاكاديميه والمحلله
السياسيه الروسيه ومن لندن الدكتور عمر
عاشور استاذ الدراسات الامنيه والعلوم
السياسيه مرحبا بكما سيده اولكا هل تمثل
التسويه نهايه فعليه لازمه فاجنر في
الداخل الروسي
هذا ان يكون هذا النزاع قد حله خاصه ان
لحلحله هذا النداء
اضاعه 24 ساعه فقط نتمنى ان لا تتكرر هذه
الاوضاع ولكنني اريد ان الفت الانتباه
للواقع التالي ان هذه الشركات العسكريه
الخاصه هي شركات او نتيجه دعوني اقول
للاعمال الروسيه الداخليه وهذه نتيجه
للسياسات الداخليه لروسيا في السنوات
العشرين
الاخيره لان روسيا كانت اتخذت طريق
الشركات
الاستثماريه الخاصه لم يكن متواجد في
الاتحاد السوفياتي وفي هذه وفي وسط هذه
الاعوام بدات هذه الشركات بتقويه موقفها
وهذه الشركات العسكريه قد ادت لها
نوعين من الاعمال السياسيه والخاصه
وهذا جعل من هذه المؤسسات اقوى مما يجب ان
تكون وكان لها فرص كبيره وممكن ان نقيم
اعمال قوات ضاجنر كشركه عسكريه خاصه وان
نتوقع انها في المستقبل
ساتحدث عن مستقبل
السيده اولغاس سنتحدث لاحقا في محور خاص
عن هذا الجانب دكتور عاشور الرئيس
البيلاروسي تحدث عن اثار كارثيه لانهيار
روسيا هذه الازمه مع كانت بهذا الحجم من
الخطوره
اكيد بهذا الحجم من الخطوره لا يوجد لا
اذكر ان هناك تهديد موازي حدث لنظام رئيس
بوتين
بهذه الطريقه يعني هو دخل مجموعه
دخلوا عبروا الحدود اولا ينادون ان يوقفهم
احد لا وحدات روسيه نظاميه ولا خلاص
الحدود دخل الى تقريبا سيطروا عليها حين
رايت الاعداد يعني كانت سريتين فقط
لم تكن هناك اعداد كبيره
والذي دفعهم للسيطره على قياده العمليات
في اوكرانيا وقياده والقياده العمليات
العسكريه الجنوبيه فهي انه لم تحدث مقاومه
من القوات النظاميه وكذلك كان هناك دعم
شعبي كما رايتم ثم سريتين اخرتين كانوا
يعني يتجولون في في الضواحي وقوه بتشكيل
كتيبه كانت تتحرك على على باتجاه موسكو
وصلت ل 200 كيلومتر ولم يكن الموضوع موضوع
مثلا
دون دماء كما يذكر كما يذكر في جوجل
اسقطه الطائرات على الاقل يعني منهم 135
نقل وكذلك طائرات على مستوى اعلى كاليوشن
التي يعني طائره كبيره بها مقر قياده يعني
بالتاكيد عسكريه لانها طائرات يعني
اتصالات
فاسقطوا ذلك لديهم مضادات
تتحرك كان ضمنها مثلا دبابات 90 فهناك
قدره عسكريه نظاميه
بمدرعات وبمضادات طائرات وبالجنود سيطرت
على مدينه بها مقر العمليات التي تدير
الحرب في اوكرانيا
وتوجهت نحو العاصمه فهو تهديد حقيقي ورد
الفعل ايضا يظهر شيء حول النظام النظام
ليس بهذا القوه والجبروت الذي ذكر لانه
غطاء حتى الخطاب الاخير هو خطاب الى حد ما
يلقي باللوم على الراس على
اما الجنود فهو يخيرهم ما بين الانضمام
للوحدات النظاميه الروسيه يسميهم كان
وطنيين يقر فعليا الرئيس بوتين ان هذه
الشركه العسكريه التي ارتكبت
رهيبه في افريقيا وفي سوريا وفي غيره وفي
اوكرانيا وفي غيرها الى بيوتهم التوجه الى
الى بيلاروسيا بالحديث عن عن تهديد النظام
السيده اولجا
تحدي
للرئيس الروسي بهذا الشكل هل يؤثر على
صوره الرئيس داخليا
سوف اسمح لنفسي ان اؤكد انه لن يؤثر لان
هذه الاعمال من مجموعات فاجنر والسيد
بريغوجين شخصيا لم تكن موجهه ضد بوتين
شخصيا بل كانت موجهه ضد
القيادات السياسيه المتواجده في روسيا قال
كثيرا السيد بريجوجن
انغا لو سمحتي ولكن نحن نعلم بان الرئيس
الروسي هو المقرر الاول في المنظومه
الامنيه والمنظومه السياسيه
نعم هذا شيء صحيح وبالرغم من هذا لا اعتقد
انا اعمل باي شكل من الاشكال سوف تؤثر
سلبيا على صوره روسيا او على تقليل او على
تقليل الثقه اتجاه النظام السياسي
والقياده السياسيه لا اعتقد هذا ابدا
المعارضات او
الاختلافات الداخليه بغض النظر لن تؤثر
على روسيا كدوله عظيمه لها موقف قوي وهذا
شيء من المستحيل تغيره وليس هناك احد
يختلف على هذا الشيء اعمال
وقوته في فاقنر هذا شيء يخصهم وكان هناك
اهداف كبيره ولكن ليس هناك شكل لدى احد ان
هناك خلافات داخليه استراتيجيه هناك
خلافات تكتيكيه ولكنها ليست بالمستوى
الاستراتيجي في نفس السياق دكتور عاشور
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي قال بان تمرد
فاغنر كشف بان بوتين اصبح معزولا وبطيء في
اتخاذ القرارات انت ما رايك به هل من
انعكاسات محتمله لهذه الازمه على صوره
الرئيس بوتين المسيطر على كل شيء في روسيا
يوجد دون شك انعكاسات لكن هو خرج الى حد
ما منتصر يعني منتصر على الاقل
الانقلاب لم يحدث الوصول الى العاصمه لم
يحدث هو لم يزح
ولكن طبعا صورته
كمسيطر على كافه الاجهزه الامنيه
والعسكريه على انه القائد الذي اسمه فوق
كل شيء او المحكم ما بين وزير الدفاع
ورئيس الاركان
وعناصر
كل هذا انتهى يعني
العناصر قائد رئيس الشركه اتحداه بشكل
مباشر ونجا من من هذا
من الفعل حتى الان يعني يمكن ان يحدث له
شيء بعد ذلك في بيلاروسيا او شيء ولكن حتى
الان هو نجا من الفعل
يعني التهديد كانها بالملاحقه القضائيه
والان يبدو ان لن تكون هناك ملاحظه قضائيه
ربما يكون هناك شيء اخر وتوجد تقريبا يعني
مديح مبطن لعناصر ف
او كانوا وطنيين وضللوا ودعاهم للانضمام
للاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه واظن انه سيكون
هناك يعني مستقبلا لو لو الامور ماشيه في
اتجاه التسريح ونزع السلاح او اعاده الدم
في المؤسسه النظاميه طيب اظن انه سيكون
تخريج الخاص بقدير يعني يضعوه تحت الحرس
الوطني الحرس الوطني رئيسه زلطه هو الحارس
الشخصي سابقا والحرس الوطني
141 هو ليست بفوق فرقه او اكبر
رسميا هي تحت ولكن تاخذ اوامرها من قديره
فيكون هناك تخريج بضم هذه العناصر كلها
تحت قائد اخر ربما لانه لن يضمه اكيد تحت
زرته تحت الحرس الوطني تحت يعني فيكون
هناك اعاده دمج مع اختيار ربما ربما حتى
انه شرعيه يعني
لكن في هذا الاطار بالتاكيد
النظام اقل قوه واقل هيبه مما كان عليه
قبل التحرك انت اشرت في اجابتك الاولى على
سرعه التقدم فاغنر من روستوف باتجاه موسكو
سيده اولغا هل هل يكشف هذا او او يعكس هذا
محدوديه قدرات الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه
الروسيه لان
قافله كبيره توجهت من روستوف باتجاه موسكو
ولم تتوقف الا بعد وساطه الرئيس
البيلاروسي
ان نتحدث عنه هل كان لاحد ان يوقفهم ام لا
نحن وانتم نحاول ان نقيم اوضاع رايناها
ولكن هناك الكثير ما لا نعلمه المفاوضات
التي تجري الان بطرق سريه او الاعمال التي
يقوم بها من المحتمل اللا نعلم عنها ابدا
من الصعب ان نقوم بهكذا تقدير لان فاجن
ارتكانت تتحرك بسرعه وان نقوم باستنتاجات
انه ما كان لاحد ليستطيع ان يوقف فاجنر
لان هذا ليس كذلك اعتقد ان المفاوضات التي
كانت موجوده والان اتضح هذا ان هذه
المفاوضات كانت منذ البدايه ولم يكن احد
يعلم عن هذا المواطنين لك ما كانوا يعلمون
هذا لذلك تقييم القدرات الامنيه والعسكريه
هذا الشيء صعب بسبب الاحداث التي وقعت
هناك الكثير من الاعمال والاحداث التي تتم
ولكنها تكون معتمه ويجب ان ناخذ هذا بعين
الاعتبار قد تكون سرعه تحرك قوات باكثر
مرتبطه بالحفاظ على الدماء ومنع سفك
الدماء الروسيه
في
الواقع كان هناك حوادث قليله لسفك الدماء
ولكنها لم تكون واسعه المساحه
والرئيس الحارس الوطني اشار الى ما سماه
انشغال القوات الروسيه بما يحصل في
اوكرانيا على كل حال دكتور عاشور
ايضا رئيس الحرس الوطني تحدث عن او او
اشار الى امكانيه ضلوع
جهات استخباراتيه خارجيه بما حصل من ما
تسميه روسيا تمرد لقوات ما رايك بهذا
السيناريو هل هو وارد
كل شيء وارد بالتاكيد يعني لا يمكن النفي
او التاكيد لكن في هذا الاطار ربما
التفسير الابرز انه صراع داخلي ما بين
الاشكاليه هيكليه انت لديك شركه خاصه بين
اقواس
ينفي الكريم ان تكون له ايات علاقه بها
منذ فتره وان هؤلاء يعني يعملون كانهم
شركه خاصه صارت في فتره ما
بقوه خمسه فرق عسكريه نظاميه و سمح لها ان
تجنن من السجون يذهب رئيسها دون ايه
صلاحيات قضائيه او تشريعيه او دستوريه
يعطي يمنح عفو يمضي معه السجين المدان بحق
عام سواء اغتصاب او قتل
عقد سته اشهر وياخذه الى الجبهه وفعل ذلك
اكثر من 30 الف مسجون مودان فهذه هذه
الصلاحيات غير مسبوقه بالاضافه ان له من
القدرات العسكريه النظاميه التقليديه
نتكلم هنا عن مثلا مجموعه مشاه خفيفه
نتكلم عن
اليات مدرعات مضادات دروع تجنيد الطيارين
تجنيد العناصر عاليه الرتب في الجيش
انضم اليهم وهو كان مسؤول عن اللوجستيات
الكامله
جيش الروسي في فتره
عناصر كبيره من وهم كثير من عناصرهم كذلك
كانوا يخدمون سابقا في الجيش الروسي فهذا
التشكيل الذي له مضبوط لا بالقياده
العسكريه النظاميه ولا بالقوانين
والدساتير ولا ولا حتى الان بالرئيس كان
يمنح او تمنح قوته او نفوذه من الرئيس
ولكن الان يعني تجاوز الرئيس فهي مساله
وقت قبل ان ينفجر هذا في وجهه من صنعه
يعني
بمجرد تطور لا يحتاج للغرب لان يتدخل يفعل
ذلك توجد شيء واحد خاص فيما يخص هذا
الموضوع في
التسريبات التي التي حدثت خاصه بانه
في اثناء معركه ضخموت كان
يعني يقول
للاوكرات الاوكرانيه سيعطيهم بعض
الاحداثيات لوجود بعض عناصر
النظاميه الروسيه التي تعمل ضده في مقابل
ان ينسحبوا من باخمد يعني يعطيهم الاحداث
المدفعيه في مقابل ان ينسحب هؤلاء هذه
ظهرت في التسبيبات وغير مؤكده طبعا هي
مرحله تحقيق واكيد في الفتره القادمه
ستظهر لتستخدم ضده دكتور من نفي دائما
روسيا لاي علاقه لها وبوصفها دائما بانها
شركه خاصه تعمل في افريقيا لان الرئيس
الروسي كشف بتمويل مباشر من وزاره الدفاع
السيده اولغا ما الذي يكشفه هذا التمويل
المباشر من وزاره الدفاع من الحكومه
الروسيه لمجموعه فاجنر
شيء بسيط ان هذه الشركه العسكريه الخاصه
دائما كانت تحصل على الاموال من الحكومه
لماذا لان هذه الايدي ايدي الشركات الخاصه
كانت روسيا عن طريقهم تحصل على اهدافها في
مختلف المناطق
الدوليه في سوريا في امريكا اللاتينيه حيث
كانت تعمل قوه فاقنار في بدايه وجودها
وهنا ليس لدي اي معلومات عن ان روسيا كانت
تنكر صورتها بشركه فاقدر هذا لم يكن موجود
كلنا كنا نفهم هذا جيدا اما كونها شركه
خاصه هذا يعني انها كانت حره في تعبئه
افرادها التي تقوم بالمهمات ولكن التمويل
بالطبع كان من الحكومه لان تمويل شركه
عسكريه
الجيش بهذا الشكل هو شيء مستحيل لشخص بغض
النظر عن راس امواله لذلك ليس لدي اي
معلومات عن ان روسيا في السابق كانت تنكر
صورتها بشركه هو مجرد التصحيح سيده
اولغاروف قالها اكثر من مره عندما كان
يسال عن فاغنر في ليبيا وفي افريقيا كان
كان يقول دائما بان هذه الشركه خاصه وليس
لنا علاقه مباشره بها على كل حال دكتور
الان بعد ما حصل وواضح من بدا شركه فاجنر
تسليم عتادها الثقيل لوزاره الدفاع واضح
من انها يعني غير متحمسه للانضمام للجيش
الروسي من سيملا هذا الفراغ في الجبهات
الاوكرانيه بتقديرك ما مصير الجبهات
الاوكرانيه مع انسحاب مجموعه كبيره من
المقاتلين مجموعه نخبه كما توصف من جبهات
اوكرانيه ونحن شاهدنا فعلا تقدم للقوات
الاوكرانيه في عدد من الجبهات في الايام
الماضيه
لكن هي اعداد كبيره يعني ليست مضخامه اولا
قتلاهم كانوا كثر للغايه بالالاف او حتى
بعشرات الالاف في في
من ناحيه يعني القوات الموجات البشريه
التي كانت تستخدم
بالسجون بالمساجين السابقين هؤلاء هذه
تقريبا ضمرت كان لديهم ايضا خسائر في بعض
في بعض عناصرهم ذات الخبره العاليه وهو ما
سبب ارق كبير لان هؤلاء يعني
سيحتاجهم لو يستمر في نشاطه في افريقيا
وفي غيرها سيحتاج حين بدا يفقدهم نظن ان
هذه من اسباب بدء التحرك لوقف هذا لكي لا
يوضع في مناطق شديده الخطوره يفقد قدرات
ويفقد نفوذه ويفقد رجاله وبالتالي يعني
تحرك الى الداخل الروسي لكن من ناحيه اخرى
هم دون شك يعني
سيؤثرون في بعض الجبهات خاصه يعني نقل
سيعود الى بيلاروش لو الامور تطورت ولنقل
في جوجل احب ان يثبت ولا مره اخرى فيمكن
ان يستخدم هذه العناصر للهجوم من الشمال
مثلا وهجوم اخر من الشمال عبر بيلاروس الى
اوكرانيا فالموضوع لم ينتهي لو استمرت هذه
الشركه يعني بهذه بهذا بهذه الاعداد
النقطه تحديدا بهذه النقطه السيده اولجا
هل هل مازال الرئيس الروسي يثق ربما بدور
مستقبلا تحديدا بقياده باختصار لو سمحت في
هذه النقطه تحديدا
من الشعب ان نتحدث عن هذا خاصه ان
المعلومات المتواجده بريجوجل هو الان في
بروسيا وبدا بانشاء قواعد له ولقواته التي
خرجت معه
والمعتقد ان عدم الثقه هو موجود بين بوتين
وبريجوجل حتى الصداقه السابقه التي كانت
موجوده في الاعوام السابقه
وضحت هذه النقطه وضحت هذه الزاويه سؤال
الاخير لك لو سمحتي باختصار ايضا رئيس
الحرس الوطني قال انه سيحصل اي الحرس
سيحصل على اسلحه ثقيله ودبابات كيف نقرا
هذا التغيير في بنيه الاجهزه الامنيه
العسكريه الروسيه باقتضاب شديد لو سمحتي
نعم هذه في تغير تغيرات حقيقيه سوف تعزز
القوات الحكوميه وقوات وزاره الدفاع بما
ان هذا الحدث وقع من شركه عسكريه خاصه حتى
وان كانت تمول من الحكومه حتى لا تكرر هذه
الاعمال انا متاكد انا تعزيز دور الحكومه
وقواتها هذا ما يجب ان ننتظره في الواقع
وهذا جزء من ثقافتنا السياسيه شكرا لذلك
هذه الاعمال عاديه شكرا السيده اولغا
كريسنياك في موسكو والدكتور عمر عاشور في
لندن شكرا لكما
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ماوى
الخبر شكرا لحسن المتابعه الى اللقاء
بامان الله ورعيت
[موسيقى]